نايكي اسم كبير في سوق الرياضه العالميه
بدا من صندوق احذيه بسياره صغيره يقودها
شاب طموح ويقف بها على بوابات مدارس
الثانويه العامه ليبيع حذاء رياضيا مريحا
بسعر 35 دولارا هذا الشاب هو فيل نايت
الذي جمع في نصف عقد ثروه تقدر بثمانيه
واربعين مليارا و300 مليون دولار فما سر
هذه الثروه ولد فيل في عام
1938 في ولايه اوريجون الامريكيه وعشق
الرياضه منذ نعومه اظفاره فشارك بالعديد
من الانشطه الرياضيه وحصد الكثير من
الجوائز في سن المبكره وحتى بعد التحاقه
بجامعه الولايه كان والد فل محاميا لصحيفه
محليه ففكر بان يعمل فيها اثناء دراسته
الجامعيه لكن والده رفض ذلك فذهب الى
المنافسه وعمل بوظيفه مسائيه لتغطيه
الاحداث الرياضيه التي شكلت شغفا في حياته
حصل في على شهاده الباكالوريوس باداره
الاعمال ثم التحق بالخدمه العسكريه قبل ان
ينجز رساله الماجستير التي تناولت جوده
الاحذيه الرياضيه الالمانيه التي غزت
السوق انذاك ومن ثم فكر بمشروع جدي لبيع
الاحذيه باسعار مناسبه فانطلق برحله الى
اليابان وزار مصنعا مختصا بالمنتجات
الرياضيه واقنعهم ببيع المنتج ببلده فحصل
على وكاله ماركه تايجر واصبح يبيع هذه
الاحذيه التي حملها بصندوق سيارته على
بوابات المدارس لطلبه الثانويه في عام
1964 وعندما كان نايت يعمل محاسبا عاما
معتمدا ومدرسا بجامعه بورتلاند استثمر مع
مدربه الرياضي بيل بورمان مبلغ 500 دولار
لاطلاق
التي عملت مع شركه اونيتساكا لتطوير احذيه
الجري وتوزيعها بامريكا الشماليه قبل ان
تفتتح متاجر للبيع بالتجزئه في ولايات
سانتامونيكا وكاليفورنيا ويوجين واوريجون
في عام 1970 اطلق الشريكان شركه احذيه
خاصه بهما حملت
وسوقت لطرازها الاول من الاحذيه وهو
كورتيز في التجارب الاولمبيه لعام
1972 وهو ما ساعدها على النجاح وتحقيق
ايرادات تجاوزت ثلاثه ملايين دولار بحلول
عام
1980 كانت شركه نايكي تستحوذ على نصف سوق
الاحذيه الرياضيه ونفذ الطرحها العامه
الاولي في بورصه نيويورك ثم واصلت هيمنتها
على سوق الرياضه لتشمل الملابس وغيرها من
ادوات الرياضه خلال سنوات الطويله الماضيه
وصل نايت الليله بالنهار ليجعل من
احدى اكبر شركات الرياضه مع عائدات تقترب
من خمسه واربعين مليار دولار وبعد 52 عاما
من بدايه الرحله بات العداء الامريكي
يتربع على قمه شركه تدر مليارات الدولارات
مع ثروه وصلت لثمانيه واربعين مليارا و300
مليون دولار
[موسيقى]